this year has been unique and one aspect
that defines 2020 is a relatively
low superhero body count but saving the
world is dangerous business
and there are still some heroic
sacrifices coming in
under the wire here are the superheroes
we've lost in 2020 so far
during the cw's huge crisis on infinite
earth's event
no one had a rougher time than oliver
queen by the end of the event he had
died twice
arrow's final season finds the hero
falling in battle against the
anti-monitor's armies
then after his body is revived without
his soul it
along with the rest of the multiverse is
destroyed by the anti-matter wave
still green arrow isn't done yet in
purgatory queen is recruited by jim
corrigan to be the new host for the
spectre
an immensely powerful being who in dc
comics is literally the wrath of god
after using his new abilities to help
flash escape the speed force
queen gives more direct help in the
battle against the anti-monitor
his new power allows him to go
toe-to-toe with the villain
and to help create the new multiverse
sadly he doesn't survive the battle for
long
dying he tells barry and sarah lance
that he's at peace
and that the new multiverse will need
them you remember what i told you
dying is the easy part the entire world
honors his sacrifice
in both the legends of tomorrow episode
that ends the event
and the arrow series finale before the
series ends we see oliver reunited in
the afterlife with felicity smoke
star girl debuted in may with an
explosive display of superhero carnage
the premiere episode opens a decade
before the events of the rest of the
series with the justice society of
america getting wiped out by the
injustice society
at first it appears the only survivor is
the sidekick stripesy
to whom starman will later entrust his
powerful cosmic staff
wildcat is killed hurled from the
headquarters just as stripey arrives
dr midnight is killed by the shade
pulled away by a massive
shadow hand starman fights off most of
the injustice society on his own before
being dealt a
mortal wound by icicle flash's helmet
and sandman's corpse are spotted during
the melee
many of the members aren't seen at all
stripes he flees the headquarters with
starman who later dies from his wounds
it's revealed in a subsequent episode
that while our man survived
the battle the monstrous solomon grundy
killed him and his wife a year later
in the animated feature justice league
dark apocalypse war
the ranks of dc's heroes are thinned
considerably
it all starts when superman leads an
assault on apocalypse the planet ruled
by the evil new god known as darkseid
after the events of previous films like
2014's justice league war
and 2019's reign of the supermen
superman is convinced the only hope
against darkseid is a preliminary
assault
we have to attack unfortunately darkseid
is ready for the attack
not only has he secretly been monitoring
the heroes through
cyborg but he's developed a new army of
powerful paradiums
parademons infused with the power of
doomsday darkseid's forces swiftly and
brutally defeat the league
some leaguers like hal jordan aquaman
and zatanna are killed outright
many are horribly maimed and enslaved by
darkseid
shazam escapes to earth but later dies
fighting in the rebellion against
darkseid along with batgirl
in a flashback we see the titans suffer
similar fates on earth
cyborg is the unwitting key to
darkseid's early victory but he's also a
big part of the villain's defeat
after arriving on apocalypse the heroes
discover that cyborg survived the first
battle with the paradiums and was
hardwired into darkseid's fortress
they managed to break him free of
darkseid's control but he's too deeply
integrated into apocalypse to be
physically removed
cyborg sacrifices himself to defeat
darkseid and save his surviving friends
teleporting the heroes back to earth
looks like i get the last word
[Music]
once they're safely gone cyborg opens a
boom tube large enough to draw in the
entire planet
it captures dark side and all of his
paradigms sending them to
no destination at all and trapping them
for all eternity
part of the reason the earth heroes get
as far as they do in justice league dark
apocalypse war is because darkseid is
occupied elsewhere
right after the mind controlled batman
learns that lex luthor has betrayed him
and darkseid we cut to the planet oa
home base of the green lantern corps
where darkseid has already slaughtered
the guardians of the universe and fires
rage
everywhere we see the corpses of guy
gardner and aurecia among the rubble
a number of lanterns including kilawog
make desperate assaults on darkseid but
he easily kills them all
the final lantern we see alive is jon
stewart badly wounded he drags himself
to owa's main
green lantern battery hoping to use its
power to defeat darkseid
the villain barely seems to notice
stewart as he speaks with batman
just as stewart is about to finish the
famous green lantern oath darkseid
orders a portion of the earth's molten
core to be teleported to owa
batman does as ordered and the molten
liquid kills jon stewart and destroys
the green lantern battery
no longer controlled by amanda waller
who harley quinn says died of cancer
the suicide squad agrees to help the
heroes take out darkseid
cheetah is killed during the initial
assault on lexcorp riddled with bullets
by the building's human protectors
the rest of the former bad guys stay on
earth with lois lane
and lex luthor to protect lex corps so
the heroes on apocalypse have a way to
return and
lex arms them with kryptonite infused
weaponry when batman learns of lex's
betrayal he sends
hordes of paradums to lexcorp where the
suicide squad makes its last stand
buckle up suicide squad
today's the day we earn our name
bane is devoured by a swarm of paradigms
while black manta is ripped in half by
one of the monsters
the surviving members of the squad
captain boomerang harley quinn
and king shark fall back behind a force
field with lane and luther
eventually the barrier fails and lex
luthor is killed by one of the paradums
lois lane calls superman on his signal
watch to say goodbye to him as they
detonate a bomb
destroying lexcorp and killing everyone
inside it
it's likely however that all these
deaths will be undone at the end of the
movie after the hero's costly victory
jon constantine
convinces flash to use his powers to go
back in time
and change the events but we never see
exactly how the events are changed or
how the world is
altered flash runs from the gathered
surviving heroes
there's a blinding flash of light and
the film ends
the fiery mystic witch fire first showed
up in 2002's jla number 61.
right before the introduction of the
short-lived power company series
in power company she was one of a group
of heroes who decided to monetize their
crime fighting careers
unfortunately for witchfire the last few
years haven't been a good time to be a
mystically themed hero
or villain in dc comics early in the
current volume of justice league dark
the horrific villain upside
down man leader of the other kind
declares war on dc's wizards and witches
while consuming the magic of his victims
in justice league dark number 15 in
order to stop the machinations of the
witch cersei
justice league dark leader wonder woman
has dr fate and zetana
send her spirit to hecate's realm where
which fire is as well
unfortunately cersei is prepared for
this she takes over diana's body while
she and her newly formed
injustice league dark lay siege to
wonder woman's teammates
upside down man appears to wonder woman
and witchfire at the end of justice
league dark number 17.
in the following issue diana makes a
deal with upside down man so he'll get
her back into her own body
before sending her back the villain
reaches for witchfire
wonder woman protests that hurting her
isn't part of the bargain
but before she can do anything to stop
him upside down man
rips out witchfire's throat cape pride
the mutant formerly known as kitty
suffers a watery fate in marauders
number six
in the new mutant nation of krakowa
mutant heroes have so far kept largely
at peace with some of the worst
mutant villains you can think of earlier
in the series emma frost had named kate
the red queen of the hellfire trading
company a position sebastian shaw wants
for his son
shinobi the peace between mutants ends
with marauders number six when shaw uses
fast-growing vines to drag pride
underwater drowning her a lot of x-men
have died and come back in the past year
because of one of krakowa's unique
advancements
a group of mutants called the five have
found a way to combine their powers to
resurrect any mutant
but while her friends discover her death
in marauders number eight by the end of
the ninth issue
the five have tried multiple times to
bring pride back with no success
in the beginning of the series we
learned that for some reason kate can't
travel
through the portals to krakowa like all
mutants are supposed to be able to do
what's going on it led some to speculate
that this was all a build up to a reveal
that somehow kate isn't a mutant
by marauders number 11 however it's
discovered that kate had just been
out of phase and simply required a
little extra help to make her way back
so in this case at least death was only
temporary
in 2019 dc comics launched a new volume
of suicide squad and it's proving to be
as blood soaked
a series as you'd expect from the name
as early as its third issue
one of task force x's most well-known
members bites the dust
and his death comes with a few different
levels of poetic justice
in suicide squad number one the squad is
sent to take down a group of meta-humans
called the revolutionaries
after the battle the revolutionaries who
survive are folded into task force
x including the aquatic metahuman finn
before that battle ends however
finn's brother scale is torn in half by
king shark
in the following issue finn makes it
clear he isn't happy about working with
the man who killed his brother
while a few electric shocks from the new
team leader lock temporarily keeps finn
at bay
it doesn't last long while finn and king
shark are on their way to another
mission in suicide squad number three
finn stabs king shark then uses his
telepathic abilities to make the nearby
sharks aware of the blood pouring into
the water
as king shark is eaten alive by the
sharks finn uses his psychic abilities
to force king shark to watch his own
death through finn's
eyes the gods of olympus were killed in
the 2019 miniseries avengers no road
home
but at the very end of the series it's
revealed the gods have been reborn as
space-faring deities
in the beginning of the new volume of
guardians of the galaxy nova seeks out
the guardians to help him stop the
reincarnated olympians who are now
waging war on innocent worlds all across
the cosmos
the guardians embark on a stealth
mission to stop them but when moon
dragon's psychic cloaking fails things
go bad for the space heroes very quickly
with the exception of star-lord all the
guardians are able to make it back to
their ship with the rescued hero
hercules in tow
meanwhile star-lord enrages zeus and the
other gods by killing hephaestus
knowing the guardians won't willingly
leave without him star-lord uses his
masks controls to launch the ship and
send it away from olympus
there's a terrible plan hey you're the
one who said you wanted to die among
friends
as zeus confronts star-lord he detonates
the black hole bomb the guardians
brought into the floating city
destroying olympus killing star-lord and
presumably the rest of the olympian gods
in the pages of justice league odyssey
things have not gone well for the
original four heroes
jessica cruz cyborg starfire and asriel
who formed their team back in 2018's
justice league odyssey
number one all but jessica cruz have
fallen under the sway of darkseid and
cruz has formed an alliance with
other cosmic heroes working with epoch
the self-styled lord of time
epoch has promised to use his revision
mechanism to rewrite darkseid's recent
crimes out of history
and those promises lead blackfyre to
take a lethal liberty with her sister in
justice league odyssey number 19.
after epoch shows them visions of their
deaths at the hands of darkseid servants
cruz's new justice league splits up to
take them down one by one
it's cruz and blackfyre who faced the
dark side controlled starfire
in spite of cruz's pleas to show
restraint and try to free starfire from
darkseid's control her sister blackfire
says that because of epoch's plan to
remake time there is no reason to spare
her now
before cruz can stop her blackfyre kills
her sister with a single powerful blast
of energy
in justice league odyssey number 20
jessica cruz still reeling
from watching her former teammate
starfire get obliterated by blackfyre
races back to the revision mechanism
while cruz and the rest of her team were
dealing with darkseid's other servants
in the previous issue
the dark side controlled azrael was on
his way to kill epoch
cruz battles asriel and seems to gain
the upper hand fairly quickly
while she didn't have a chance to speak
to starfire before blackfyre killed her
in the previous issue cruz desperately
tries to reach asriel as they fight
but darkseid's control over the gotham
hero is complete and her words fall on
deaf ears
asriel knocks cruz to the ground and
appears to be about to deliver the
killing blow when blackfire arrives and
vaporizes azrael with a single energy
blast
azrael is best known as jean-paul valley
the man who
before dc's line-wide new 52 event
re-road continuity
took over the mantle of batman when
bruce wayne's back was broken by the
villain bane
for most of the first season of star
girl the new jsa's teenage recruits
managed to survive despite some dicey
confrontations with the injustice
society of america
but in the episode brainwave junior one
of star girl's allies is killed by her
own father
the new jsa infiltrates the injustice
society's underground headquarters in
part to save brainwave
not long before brainwave wakes from his
coma his psychic powers begin
manifesting in his son henry
in spite of his father's violent past
henry is convinced he can get brainwave
to turn against the injustice society
sadly henry is wrong about his father's
moral compass
as the jsa escaped from the injustice
society's tunnels
brainwave confronts his son and reveals
to him that it was he
not icicle as henry believed who killed
henry's mother jordan didn't kill your
mother
i did a brief battle ensues between
henry and his father and henry is
quickly overpowered
henry and the rest of the jsa are
separated by metal bars and henry
uses his final moments to apologize to
yolanda for his betrayal
brainwave uses his telekinesis to
collapse the tunnel on top of his son
killing him after henry's death
brainwave reveals to icicle that somehow
killing his son
amplified his own powers while the
injustice society's original plan was to
use brainwave's powers to enslave six
different states
brainwave believes his powers are now
substantial enough to take over half the
country
i'm about to be in the heads of millions
reprogramming them all for the better
in agents of shield's seventh and final
season the team loses one of its most
beloved and unique members
at the end of after before while yo-yo
finally manages to reawaken her super
speed it isn't enough to fix the
zephyr's time engine
this leads to the time loop episode as i
have always been
in which daisy keeps waking up and
re-experiencing the same few hours
specifically she experiences the zephyr
caught in a temporal storm that
threatens to wipe
everyone on board from existence simmons
knows how to fix the time engine
but the knowledge is trapped behind a
mental block she created to keep the
location of fits
safe when the heroes remove the implant
they discover the only way to fix the
time engine is a device
inside enoch and the removal would mean
his death when the chronicom hero learns
of this he doesn't bother to wait while
his friends debate the moral quandary he
reaches into his own body and yanks it
out
daisy and coulson stay with enoch as he
dies he tells them about his feelings of
loneliness and warns them that he has
seen the future
and that while they will survive their
current adventure it will be their final
mission as a team
the season 7 agents of shield episode
stolen has a high inhuman body count
and the last to fall is ya ying daisy's
mother
the older version of zhao ying was
killed in the show's second season by
calvin zabo
but while that older version died after
turning on her daughter
in 1983 a younger zhao ying dies
protecting daisy
nathaniel malek locks horns with daisy
and jiaying aboard the zephyr
using the quake abilities he duplicated
from daisy but malek points out that
because of the time travel daisy and the
agents have been experiencing
he's actually been using the quake
powers longer than daisy
if you haven't done the math i've had
these powers a lot longer than you have
although he's able to initially brush
her aside without too much effort
xiaoying jumps in to protect her
daughter using her life absorption
abilities on the villain
unfortunately malik is able to resist
her powers long enough to break xiang's
neck
killing her daisy rallies after her
mother's death and malik is frightened
at her display of power
when mae shows up firing her gun at
malik he runs away
sadly there's no saving jiaying forager
harley quinn lady shiva justice league
dark apocalypse war
intriguin justice league dark apocalypse
war
alex winters catalyst prime seven days
number four
summit catalyst prime seven days number
six
dr echo weapons plus world war four
number one
lee marvel's agents of shield 1983
gordon
marvel's agents of shield check out one
of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite superheroes are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you